[Music]
are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepperi
smort excuse me you need to watch
yourself I'm sorry cop all right let's
everybody just stay calm here oh what
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that
dancing this is
dancing what is happening I'm diffusing
a
[Music]
situation dancing Captain must capture
image of a
lifetime why is my phone always dead I
paid $13 for it don't worry Jak I got
it no my hands are covered in butter
from making butter come on it must
record must record camera on all right
here we go dancing over s situation
confused
no is uh everything okay Santiago no I
lost my ring did you see where it went
actually it's behind one of these three
doors why don't you pick one are you
trying to Monty Hall me it's
unbelievable I don't need Monty Hall
ruining my place of work when Monty Hall
has already ruined my home life come on
Sir the math thing isn't the problem
night shift's keeping you and Kevin
apart you two just need a bone what did
you say don't say it again I said you
two need a
bone
how dare you detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business bone don't ever speak to me
like that
again Jake hurry up I'm starving sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry I just had to
grab my
[Music]
wallet gentlemen
fine I was trying something and it
didn't work and now it's time to send in
our cute little secret weapon I'm ready
Captain I love the nickname no Charles
not you I was talking about cheddar oh
right obviously over the past month I've
had him trained to retrieve plaques and
now boy it's time to make Daddy proud
yes sir I could not have been more
clearly talking to the
[Music]
dog good
morning
hi this is for you thanks quite a big
package you got there oh I apologize for
the dou on Tandra I can be such a
Samantha really you don't seem like a
Samantha well I'm actually a combination
of all four characters five of you count
the city of New York York
yes another Sex in the City guilty as
charged my favorite season has to be the
third one everything was going right for
Carrie her face was on every bus her
column was the Talk of the Town and she
met everyone's favorite F maker Aiden
Shaw sure she melted down when he tried
to introduce her to his parents and she
flipped out when she bumped into big
getting out of that cab with Natasha
whom he had married who can blame her
they barely knew each other the best
episode that year was episode 6 entitled
are we you know the one Carrie was
all in her head because she and Aiden
weren't having sex meanwhile across town
Charlotte couldn't stop having sex and
Samantha Sam was just being Samantha the
season finale that year was entitled
cockadoodle doo cocka dooodle Doo Roger
that whoops I hate big Carrie should
have ended up with Mel barishnikov what
he slapped her are you
[Music]
insane
Bingo got the file preparing for
extraction
no screaming
Peralta if you ask me they never should
have made the movie Abu Dhabi Abu don't
bother wow I'm going to use that please
do have a nice
day whoa wait hold on stop both of you
that pass is only for the ninth floor is
it all right let me see that envelope oh
um actually I can't show you that
because it's
okay I asked him to come down and mail
that I just need to put my return
address on it
and there you go thanks I know just
where to put that oh there's Samantha
again you ready for this one Daddy's
daughter an is getting divorced hate to
say I told you so but I told you so you
know we should fix her up with Bern his
son what's his name the doctor oh Vince
and he's not a doctor he's a pharmacist
although that might appeal to an pop
pop Greg you're such a crack up forget
an who should we fix him up with huh oh
now s you know I'm still getting over
the tragic loss of my wife she was such
a strong female woman with nice heavy
breasts I pity the child Who Lies
Beneath this solar system hey Captain
something's going on with this Heist you
tell us everything you know and we'll
tell you everything we know no I'd
rather not jokes on you we don't know
anything well good day then wait why are
you sweating I'm not sweating oh I've
had enough heart attacks to know what
sweating looks like that's
[Music]
sweat well if I'm sweating as you play
it's because I was watching an exciting
video on the net really what it was a
video of an American gymnast is leotard
ripped exposing his butt it's highly
erotic you're lying I teach just install
blocker software thanks to Mah uh yes
but they didn't install it on my
computer because I'm a captain you don't
look hot and bothered at all to me show
us the eroda gentlemen I assure you
there's nothing to see now if you'll
excuse me I have to grab some fresh
[Music]
air good boy cheddar bring me that
kabot wait a minute this isn't the
championship cbond this is some common
cbond you're not cheddar this just some
common Diaz sent us the list of
favors she needs us to do for she didn't
hold back first she wants us to move all
her furniture into storage okay then
file her taxes for really and then she
wants us to type up an email these
letters to Pento in Argentina are they
sexual in nature crazy sexual but we
can't say no she's behind bars and we
made a promise right you're right oh
also she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting Idol so she wants us to take it
out once a day here I think you should
do this you're more the biker type I've
seen you use a toothpick in public
motorcycles are death machines I have
three kids I'm not risking it are you
saying my life matters less because I
don't conform to society's
heteronormative child Centric ideals are
you really playing the gay card right
now go
Queen will you please read the trans
scripts of the threats he's received yep
die die die die halt die okay little
obvious you will drown in your own blood
better although I would have gone with
the whole I'm going to staple my face
onto your face thing human skin mask
classic the next one is I'm going to
send you off the deep end drowning and
deep end almost sounds like he's talking
about a swimming pool it's hes aha who's
hes Colin hes the freestyle killer he
took out an entire 4x100 meter relay
swim team in
Marco now you say
Polo punke the freestyle killer man how
come all the killers you caught had such
cool names the best name I ever brought
in was narrow shoes Sam because his
shoes were narrow and his name was Sam I
get it yeah you get it well Captain
looks like you needed our help after all
together we figured out it was HS and
together we're going to take him down
because together we can do anything here
we go
I'm finding haes
Alone come back at you
Jake it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why
I'd like to
play I'd say she's in line at the
bank this is fun it is fun but you're
all wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mle
man there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us
now there was a problem at the bank God
damn sir we're tracking a triple
murderer who stole $21 million and all
you can think about is meline
wch you're right what's that now before
I came to the 99 9 I was riding away
behind a desk in the public relations
department all I wanted was the chance
to do good police work again I just got
it and I blew it thinking about that
devil
toad I'm tired of politics let's get
that punk blood so this is amazing of
course we have no idea where he is but I
love where your head's at he has no
family maybe there was a girlfriend or
someone he worked with at the coffee
shop the coffee shop why would someone
who knows they have $21 million coming
take a minimum wage job because he
needed access to that building because
that's where the money's hidden all
right we got to get there quick maybe we
should take the
chopper use that Chopper death blade
side Winder it's go time Roger that wet
blanket no from now on call
me
velvet
Thunder okay you reled for the first
time all week it's just the two of us
I'm right here I escaped using some of
the lube boil sent too it got everywhere
I had to change yeah and your new shirt
is very aggressive and confusing is the
pineapple the sled or is it calling
someone else a sled clearly the
pineapple is the
[Music]
yeah